let's now talk about the shutdown the
weekend has gone by it has come and gone
the shutdown now continues into I guess
we're now into week four because it's
it's been more than three weeks not yet
for I think so I believe that we're in
week four of the shutdown at this point
and it's kind of becoming the biggest
joke running and I'm going to speak more
this week to a couple of friends who
work under the Department of Homeland
Security I texted with them over the
weekend none of them are getting paid
there's this unclear sort of big picture
of all of the people under DHS that are
not getting paid who may support the
shutdown because they want the wall but
it's not clear that all of them do and a
lot of them aren't getting paid because
Trump has shut down the government in
order to get from the money for the wall
which they might support I mean it's a
mess at this point and Republicans
actually had the opportunity to get
Donald Trump to end the shutdown
Republicans came up with a bill to end
the shutdown they negotiated it with
other Republicans and Donald Trump has
now rejected him there's been this
growing list of Republicans and I told
you last week some Republicans are
starting to realize that the shutdown is
starting to have political implications
for them there are also real-world
implications on a ton of people in this
country who aren't getting paid part of
Miami Airport has now been shut down and
I've pointed out that the airport shut
down stuff could become a real crippling
factor for industry there are
Republicans who say it's time to get
beyond this they are saying we're
willing to end it without funding for
the wall at least initially of course
that was the reason Trump shut down the
government so over the weekend Senate
Republicans who want to end the shutdown
were able to negotiate with other
Republicans a bill that would do exactly
that and what they came up with was well
we'll fund some departments that are
currently shut down we'll fund some
border security but we're not going to
specifically fund the wall will let
committees later sort out whether or how
we're going to fund the wall so a block
of Republicans negotiated this with
other Republicans okay Republicans who
want to reopen government without the
wall against the Republicans who say no
we absolutely need the
all to reopen government they agreed
okay Republicans agreed with Republicans
to do this and then Donald Trump
rejected it Mike Pence and chief of
staff Mick Mulvaney brought it to Trump
and Trump immediately shot it down and
so the question I'm going back to is the
one we asked last week which is this
Trump feel like he's winning here and it
appears that he does completely whacked
out Senator Lindsey Graham says quote I
think we're stuck I just don't see a
path forward I don't see a way forward
and Trump reportedly told Graham and
some other senators that he believes he
is actually winning on this it's also
hilarious but incredibly depressing that
Mitch McConnell is number one managing
to stay almost completely out of the
news how I don't know because he's one
of the major players in keeping
government shutdown but McConnell is
rejecting deals that other Democrats
have put forward which are identical to
deals that Republicans have previously
agreed to and they aren't even taking
seriously the proposals of some of the
more moderate Republicans beyond this
one which was again brought to Trump and
Trump immediately rejected it so what
you've got to understand here Pat is
that House Democrats are passing
Republican bills to reopen government
Mitch McConnell won't even put them up
for the Senate to vote on and we're
supposed to believe that everybody is
equally to blame for this fiasco yeah
that sounds like Trump is losing friends
in his own party and he's really not in
a position to do that not with the
Democrats taking over power in the house
and starting over starting up a bunch of
new investigations not with the Muller
report coming out maybe in the next you
know weeks or months he really has to
hold steady that Republican base make
sure that he's getting along with
Republican senators because they could
end up turning on him they could take a
look at what's going on with a shutdown
here and decide that it would be a lot
easier to work with Mike Pence instead
and announce the guy I wonder I mean
okay so I think back when we when I
think about would Trump be punished by
voters if he allowed government to be
reopened without funding for the wall I
think back to this guy that called in I
don't remember his name but just the
outrageous Trump supporter who called in
who talked all about how
wall the wall the wall he supports Trump
because of the wall and I said to him
okay
what could Trump do that would make it
so that you don't vote for Trump in 2020
and this guy said well he's got to build
he's got to build the wall and so then I
said alright so if Trump doesn't build
the wall are you saying you will not
vote for him in 2020 and the guy
immediately backed off and basically
said well actually I'm not really sure
about that if he tried to build it but
Democrats prevented him from building it
then maybe I would still vote for him
and that's why I actually think Pat that
he's not going to be punished even
though it's embarrassing that he said
Mexico would pay for it which they never
would I think even if he allows the
government to reopen without funding for
the wall most of his followers aren't
gonna go and vote for Elizabeth Warren
right or Tulsi Gabbard I just don't
think they'll punish him I think the
best way out politically for everyone in
this scenario is for Trump to cave to
pass the budget without the funding for
the wall and then to declare his
national emergency say he's going to use
the military to build the wall then the
courts strike it down because in that
scenario he can just point to these
liberal activist judges and blamed them
for the reason why the wall wasn't able
to be built and and yet he's still able
to go to in front of his supporters and
say that I did the best I could I tried
to institute a travel ban that got shut
down by the courts I tried to build a
wall that got shut down by the courts
I'm only one person here I can only do
so much that's also the best because it
will have been struck down according to
him by the liberal activist judges
increasingly appointed by him right I
mean like with every passing month Trump
is responsible for more and more of the
judges that are actually on the courts
politically you may be right I actually
thought of another idea just playing on
Trump's a lack of reading what if
someone just goes to trump and says mr.
president we got the money for the wall
we got it in the bill but we need you to
sign it right now and there's no money
for the wall in the bill Trump doesn't
read he's not going to read the bill and
even if he does read it he probably
doesn't understand the way that those
bills are written if Trump puts his
signature on it before assed
forgets a chance to read it government
gets reopened Trump will go and say he
got money for the wall it obviously
won't be built because there was no
money for the wall in the bill and
eventually Trump will realize that and
it'll be a big loss that may actually be
the best path forward but of course
Republicans aren't going to do that to
him or at least I can't imagine that
they're going to how long will this go
on when do you think it will end do you
think Trump will get his five billion
for part of the wall which of course
would only be a fraction of the wall
send me your thoughts